this is a non-stop day of goodies of all kinds of
fandom entertain guys we are going to watch today
dwayne zilrock johnson has dropped the black
adam official trailer call corey at 5 45 in
the morning like hey man working on obi-wan but
i think this is dwayne johnson black adam movies
coming the trailers coming in like 15 minutes
man he just showed up here so thank you court
for being here he knows the black adam comics
really well wouldn't want to do this without him
guys thank you so much for being here please leave
a like if you can this video today is sponsored by
storyblocks um partnering up with them has been
absolutely wonderful a lot of people say this you
know supporting them supports the channel and it's
just a common phrase but it really does because
we've been hiring a lot more people to help out
around with the channel lately example a and all
that kind of partnering goes to help partner with
people like him so thank you sir blocks more on
them after the trailer and of course stick around
for uh koi's thoughts after because he's going to
have a lot to say because he's coy even when he's
tired koi has a lot of thoughts corey thoughts
black adam what have your powers ever given to you
i was a slave until i died
wow i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
yours look a little pointer
now i kneel before no one
in this
heroes don't kill people
well i do
my vision has shown me the future
you have two choices you can be
the destroyer of this one god damn
that's up to you
behind you whoa did he just catch a rocket
river my goodness jay-z at the end not mad at it
that was epic i feel like that moment with the
planes was kind of a jab at uh iron man to show
that he is not the hero where man were like let me
hang on the planes and he was like the [__] this
yeah yeah also the doctor mirroring doctor strange
parallels there's gonna be a lot of interesting
comments here because technically jsa is the first
superhero team ever the justice society of america
yes the justice side of america from the 1940s
uh but they're the first team so i think there's
gonna be a lot of interesting conversation
about like what's referencing what and what's
referencing the comic books this is what's like
popular in the world and also from the looks
of this i mean the rock's been wanting to make
this for 11 years this is like his deadpool to
ryan reynolds it's a long run together yeah and
as such i do think the script has improved and
things have evolved so the movie that he wanted
to make can now exist because of technology but
it's interesting where we don't have a superman
really right now in the dc universe so we
have this anti-hero that has a lot of superman
parallels so i actually get more of like a darker
alternate universe earth 2 superman vibe than
necessarily even like a shazam spin-off obviously
this ties into the shazami in that whole world i
think shazam 2 and this are going to come together
for a third thing but this gave me a lot of
superman vibes personally wow sounds like that the
journey dwayne johnson has had along the way is
quite a lot of blocks he's had to
overcome uh it's called the story story
guys that reminds me of something what's that
john this thing thank you to storyblocks for
sponsoring this video being the cinematic
artisans we obviously are we are always in
search of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap is good
and if you're a content creator or filmmaker or
anything in between you're probably in a similar
position it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking the bank
or burning yourself out in the process which is
why i heavily encourage you guys to check out
what storyblocks has to offer cheap is good do you
feel like this is their way of telling us that the
videos could be looking better yes whether it's
the credibility of an exotic establishing shot
the soothing comfort of the perfect music bed or
just the satisfaction of increasing your graphical
capability storybox has an incredibly
inclusive and diverse library of faces
places sounds titles transitions filters and
effects and more over a million assets royalty
free and available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so affordable
this is this is quite affordable they have
multiple subscription levels to suit your exact
needs whether you're an independent indie solo
creator or a whole team so if you want to learn
more head on down to our link in the description
box and get started that's at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video thank you again
to storyblocks for uh partnering up with us this
month seriously this guy cost a fortune a fortune
a fortune every word every year right diet fraud
he's the only one we've hired is great i don't
know what this is a product of that yeah i'm not
as obviously as familiar as you uh when it comes
to black adam i've read like the shazam comics
where he is the villain in that games and seen
animated movies or black adam is he's working
along with the heroes because he has to because of
this what's at stake but i've never actually read
anything where he is just a pure anti-hero to my
understanding he does eventually have his own run
where he is just pure anti-hero i feel like
this is only anti-hero though that i don't get
the sense of him being truly a villain it seems
like it's doing that comic book movie thing not
not quite what sony does dude like they're going
a little bit more wrestling attitude with it and i
kind of like that kind of wish though usually not
so you get some of these images here that uh look
like they gotta be from conduct that's like his
his domain kind of like doctor doom's latvia yes
and i think this is gonna be i've always seen him
as like a doctor doom meets superman and that's
what i got a lot from this trailer we haven't
really seen an on-screen doctor doom really so i
think it'll be interesting to see how audiences
adjust to someone that they don't always like
the choices that are made but you always like
the rock like his inherent charm and charisma
i think is gonna sell yeah like there's not gonna
be a moment where you're rooting against him even
if he's doing you know unspeakable things and
i do think there's a child that pops up in this
trailer a few times with a star in his shirt he's
he's protecting him that kid's head is the enemy
no but i just think we're gonna see him like go
from that i feel like that kid's gonna be the
reluctant okay i'm gonna help this kid like he's
gonna be like ah you're a bother and then evolve
into like protecting and i think we're gonna see
a lot of those arcs where we're like okay the jsa
the first might be kind of corralling him
into doing things eventually he does them
on his own like as a journey so i think the jsa
is inherently good he's inherently bad and that
kind of meets a middle ground okay so that's why
we're getting characters like adam and hawkman
yeah because like i mean i've been wanting to see
aldous hodge as a superhero for a long time that
dude steals every movie he's in and hawkman is a
very important character he's got his own planet
there's a lot of stuff going on with the more uh
cosmic scale of dc we're gonna see this expand out
and i think hawkman is a really great gateway into
that world into other worldly characters because
the phenar thanegarians it's hard to say in the
morning the thanegarians are a really noble breed
of warrior that will tie into where i think we can
bring the dc universe and making it feel bigger
and bigger and bigger and i think this is a great
start to that true i remember when we first saw
the uh black adam footage of the little bits and
they had the dc trailer you were commenting on how
it seemed reflective of like a combination of
michael bay zack snyder the real godly quality
that snyder was trying to capture so now that we
saw a full trailer humphrey what do you think i'm
really excited to return to the world of the
scorpion king i think this is gonna really top
the first one no it definitely gave me that gods
among us quality that i feel like is signature to
dc especially as compared to marvel this was an
interesting blend of tones i feel like for the
first chunk of the trailer you had this unified
tone and then you get kind of like a a joke bit
and then you get you know kind of uh you have
your action your superhero requisite stuff but
then you have some more like psychedelic things
like you alluded to with things kind of broaching
even on dr strange imagery so i'm excited and
curious to see how they're going to separate
some of these characters who do have similar
counterparts in other universes and just to see
what this amounts to in terms of its relation
to earth because what i got from this trailer
is a lot of godly characters doing a lot of things
here um and i i don't know i'm curious to see how
all of that intermingles because right now i feel
like it could be could take place kind of anywhere
how does this tie into joker two hule vucus
clearly this is the next todd phillips well
what i think is interesting is is you know
we've had the dc universe at large and it's
been shifting and that's actually thanks for
that tangent it sometimes feels independent with
things like joker and also sometimes feels like
it's building to a more shared universe and also
you've got characters like aquaman and wonder
woman who have done both been a team member and
been singular this to me feels like it could be
kind of the restart like you can really branch
out from here because you're bringing in the
first superhero team you can make their own solo
movies you've got a different kind of first time
i've ever heard that this could be the restart
dc could go okay post flash point this is really
good timing for this jumping on point as you're
speaking of tone i think the rock's got a very
specific kind of film where he has his humor his
action and those things and this looks like
a blend of what the dceu whether or not they
keep it that way and the rock movies would look
like combined and i think that's a net positive
for dc building out into having like marvel does
different styles of movie like you've got you know
everybody talks about it at nauseam guardian space
opera ant-man heist et cetera et cetera a rock
genre is very popular it's gonna do very well and
i think it's a good way to bring people back into
the fold you already see like dc easter eggs
being planted here which is kind of why i was
speaking of the the shared universe like the the
name of the electronics store on the truck and
i do think we're gonna see a lot
of him expanding into his domain
like there's a lot you can do with the rock being
a protector that would allow us to be like i guess
he can make that bold choice do you think the
rock will actually be somewhat of an anti-hero
or will he maintain his clean-cut family-friendly
image i mean we see someone get murked pretty
quickly in the trailer uh we also see you
know that's about it do you think that's it
i feel like you're probably right i think well
you see him like vaporized dude in that earlier
footage we see him like can you turn that guy
to dust i mean dc's a little more is more bold
i feel like the rock is going to push it too
like he's loved this again for over a decade
why didn't he do the accent because they might
have tested it and that worked like people might
be so familiar they re-shot the whole movie no
but people might be so familiar with the rock
that hearing the rock with an accent might have
turned people off like if you if you know an actor
to that level scorpion like in the scorpion but
now like if they're it's a the rocks dc movie i
think they're leaning into the rock you know what
i mean so maybe they don't want him to be doing
a thing other than being the rock like that that
portrayal is what they wanted i'm guessing all i
know is that when i moved closer to you i was like
we can get these videos up faster yeah and now
knowing how much talking has been done you've
asked me many questions i'm going to get this
up by twitter than any other video we've ever
anyone you want here we are you know what's great
it took me 11 years for the rock to hand this out
we're going to get this out in at least 11 hours
yeah that's right baby no koi thanks for being
here um yeah we were on an all-nighter you at
least got two hours two hours of sleep so
you you carried us through again once again
we we write on your back read some dr fake comics
i think those would be the ones that are going
to be the hardest to really like navigate by
the word by the word but they're great doctors
someone have told you that you can increase
your commission by advising your bottom line
i think it's really important
there's a door right there